If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you will also appear with him in glory.
Man, did Nick do a great job with that intro video? Hey, amen. Uh,
just such a good reminder of the truths that we will learn and
be struck by as we venture into this journey through the New Testament book of
Colossians.
And so I would invite you to turn there with me if you're not already there. Uh,
if you want to keep that place in your Bible, we'll be in there for a long time.
You saw in the video that we have bookmarks out there that you can go grab right
under the cross. We have stickers and magnets as well. Uh, phone lock screens,
just kinds of things like that. Not for our logo purposes,
but that you would keep these things in front of you and this truth
of Christ above all for the next couple months, just to be reminded constantly.
And you'll see why as we get into it here.
You can also visit the new bookstore right over here. If you want to, uh,
get a Colossians journal.
You can take notes in that alongside the text of scripture there if that's for
you. But speaking of newness, uh, as Brandon mentioned a little bit,
is it not exciting to feel the life and excitement and,
and all kinds of things as school is about to start?
Some of you're not so excited about that, but, uh, most of us are. And,
and then the building refresh nearing completion, not fully done,
but almost there. I mean, I just wanna say thank you to a ton of people.
I can't name all of you who worked on this to get us all, uh,
where we are right now and how beautiful it is. Uh, but,
but I also wanna just stop for a second.
I think we need to do this and just appreciate what God has given us here. Uh,
I know I said last week, it's not about the stuff for the building,
it's about the people. But,
but we can still be grateful for how God has provided for
us in these ways where we're now debt free.
Where we were also able, the,
the chairs you're sitting on obviously aren't broken in. They're brand new. Uh,
the older chairs that had been broken in for about 20 years, uh,
we were able to bless other churches with and other ministries.
And so the kingdom, as Psalm 67, very clearly says,
we are blessed to be a blessing.
And so God gave us so we can give.
And that's an incredible truth to remember as a church, as we go forward.
We're blessed to be a blessing.
But as we look ahead to this journey through Colossians,
apart from a couple special weeks over the next, uh, couple months,
it's gonna be a journey straight through the book. Uh,
we'll start today and we'll end right before Thanksgiving.
And we're gonna see its train of thought as we go through the whole thing.
And over those 13 weeks or so, we're going to learn the,
the one primary point that I hope we get. It's all over.
Everything that we've got, of course, it's all over the logo. You're gonna see,
and I hope you get this, I hope I get this into our souls,
is that Christ is above all,
like if you boil Colossians down, as as I've put that, Christ is above all,
he's above all other religions.
He's above all idols that you and I can search after he's above all of our
sin. He's above everything.
And as I've been studying this book,
I'm so excited to be able to share the truth of that into
our lives of how that changes everything.
What we're gonna do today though,
is we're gonna look at just the first two verses of the book and get our
bearings and what we need to know about Colossians before we venture into it's
depths. Now, kids,
there used to be these things that you would keep in your car called maps and
uh, they,
you'd get 'em from like a rest stop or somewhere else and you'd go pick it up
and you'd keep it in there. And, and when you picked it up, it,
you noticed when you first got it, it was all folded really crisply and neatly.
And it was just really well done from the tourism or whoever did that. The,
the problem was that once you unfolded it, you could never get it back together,
right? And so what you would do is you'd have to unfold it and look around and,
and as you would take it out in your car and it covers three-fourths of the
dash, you would put it out there and you'd say, okay, where are we?
We need to know where we're going. We need to have the,
the legend of the map to see what this, this little,
little figurine is. And what, what does that mean?
We're going here and looking for landmarks because of the map.
And you know where you are, you know where you're going.
That's what we're going to do kind of today,
is we're gonna unfold the map of Colossians and lay it on the table and say,
okay, where do we need to go? Where are we going?
What does it tell us about this letter?
So we get a get an a lay of the land of Colossians.
So there will be a little bit of academic side of this.
We're gonna have to go through just some details of things.
I know it's super easy to check out when you start to get to that academic
world, but, but listen,
these things are really important for us to understand how
Colossians works and why it says what it says.
So we need to follow through with that.
And you'll see it right here as we begin in verses one and two,
looking for Christ above all,
Paul, an apostle of Christ Jesus, by the will of God and Timothy,
our brother,
to the saints and faithful brothers in Christ at Colossae grace to you and peace
from God, our Father, God, even in these short verses,
deeply impact our hearts. Show us what you want us to see here.
Set up the rest of our study through Colossians,
where this truth of Christ above all would change us deeply.
Holy Spirit, I can't do that. We can't do that. I can't say enough.
You need to speak through your word today and every day.
Thank you that you promise whenever we preach your word and we study your word,
that you'll meet us there. We pray you would today in Jesus' name. Amen.
So first things first, as with any letter, we need to know who wrote it. Uh,
when you get a letter at home, same thing. Who wrote this? Now,
ancient letters were a little bit different than the way we write ours today.
You write a letter today started with like, dear Bill, right?
And then you write the letter and you sign it at the bottom.
The ancient letters would often start with the name of the author at the
beginning as a way to greet the reader and as a way to validate authenticity.
So they pick up this parchment and they see the name of the author right at the
beginning. They know they can trust it. And so that's what we see here, right?
Paul is mentioned straight away as one of the authors.
So Paul was here. Now here's, here's a bit of a side note. Paul probably was,
was dictating these words to ascribe 'cause we believe Paul was in prison at
this time, probably chained up in prison.
So you can't really write very well when you got chains on.
So he's saying these words to somebody else and they're writing it.
But that doesn't cause us to doubt the authenticity of this because look at the
very end. Just turn a page over, very end of chapter four, verse eight.
Verse 18 says,
I Paul write this greeting with my own hand.
Remember my chains grace, be with you. So Paul,
at some point he said, Hey,
I need to let them know that I'm actually involved here.
So he somehow figured out a way to, to write his own little thing.
I write this with my own hand. It's indifferent font.
It's all the things grace be with you. Remember my chains?
So Paul wrote, so who, who was Paul? First of all,
we need to know this Paul figure. Well,
this was the man who was formerly known as Saul,
who was persecuting the church initially. But then in Acts chapter nine,
God knocks him down, blinds him and says, no,
you're mine. Radically saves Paul,
but not only called Paul into his family, the family of God,
he also called Paul to be an apostle of Jesus.
That's the word we see here in verse one.
That word apostle means messenger used in a lot of different contexts,
but primarily the way the Bible uses it most is in reference to the original
12 who were with Jesus. Now, not all the 12,
'cause Judas didn't make it so there were 11. But then in Acts chapter one,
Mathias is added as one of the 12.
And so now they have 12 what they called apostles.
And so these were designated as eyewitnesses to
all that Jesus had said and done.
And they were seen as the authorities over the church at the time as the gospel
was going out, as letters are being written,
the apostles could be the ones to say, no, no, that's not of Jesus.
He never said that. Or yes, that's exactly what Jesus said and did.
Here's the gospel, here's the truth. Here's yeah, that's James.
He wrote that they could all kind of collectively oversee the process
of the gospel spreading. That was the apostles,
they were messengers, but they were a little bit differently. But then Paul
later was given the same designation.
The problem was that Paul wasn't directly with Jesus.
And so how could Paul be called an apostle too?
'cause he didn't actually see Jesus do any that he did. More or less.
We assume he didn't see anything. So how can Paul get this designation?
Well, remember, remember what happened on the, the road in Acts nine,
Jesus shows up, even though Jesus already ascended to heaven.
Jesus shows up on the road, meets Paul, he transforms his life,
blinds him,
sends him away for a couple of years where Jesus then begins to teach him. Now,
Jesus was teaching through people all of these things, yes, but,
but Jesus affirmed the apostleship of Paul.
He says, I'm a, I'm an apostle two here. Paul says it himself. Well,
how can he say that? Well,
here's how he wrote it to the Corinthians in one Corinthians
chapter 15. He,
he's recounting his authority to preach the gospel and declare what the gospel
really is. He says it this way in one Corinthians 15, three through 10,
he says, I delivered to you as of first importance. What I also received,
that Christ died for our sins in accordance with the scriptures. He was buried.
He was raised on the third day in accordance with the scriptures.
So after his resurrection, here's what happened. Verse five,
he appeared to CFUs and then to the 12. That's the 12 apostles.
And then he appeared to more than 500 brothers at one time.
Most of whom are still alive, though some have fallen asleep.
If you want to check. It basically is why he said that.
Then he appeared to James and then to all the apostles. And last of all,
as to one untimely born, he appeared also to me,
meaning later he appeared to me, verse nine,
for I am the least of the apostles unworthy to be called
an apostle because I persecuted the church of God,
but by the grace of God, I am what I am.
And his grace toward me was not in vain, right?
So by the way, if you want a life verse verse 10, by the grace of God,
I am what I am, right?
That's a great one to just throw on your wall and never forget. It's nothing.
It's God's grace in you that brings it about. But that's what Paul is saying.
He didn't pull back from describing his position in Christ. He's saying,
I am an apostle. You guys can trust that.
But he's humble about it because he says it very clearly, this is not my work,
this is all God's deal. I was trying to persecute the church and God said, no,
you're mine and I'm gonna use you in powerful ways.
So he knew it was by God's will, it was through God's work.
But he wanted to state his credentials to these colossian Christians because
they didn't know him.
We believe that most likely Paul never visited Colossae. So he,
they didn't know him personally. So they're, they're having to,
to trust his position. Most likely.
We believe Eris was the one who planted the church in Colossae when,
when Paul was in Ephesus, which is close by in Acts 19,
he probably sent Ariss who was from Colossae.
He sent him to his hometown and said, Hey, go preach the gospel over there.
We'll see Ariss show up all throughout the book.
But Paul was like, Hey guys, listen,
you need to know what you're hearing and reading from me.
You can trust it because God called me to be an apostle.
And so he's introducing himself. But notice even in his introduction,
even as Paul stands up and says to these people, yeah,
I'm an apostle of Christ Jesus.
He's not bragging in that what he's doing is even there.
The focus is on Christ.
I'm an apostle of Jesus Christ by the will of God.
Like the focus is not on Paul's position. The focus is on God himself.
It's on Christ.
The emphasis is on following Jesus. He's like, I'm not just, I'm an apostle.
He's like, I'm an apostle of Christ by his grace, by his work,
I'm an apostle of Christ.
But we also see another name here we see Timothy,
and this is used as another author, Paul and Timothy,
another author of this letter to the Colossians. Now,
if we wanna be really technical,
we could also add the Holy Spirit as a third 'cause Holy Spirit inspired this
'cause scripture for us. We would assume that, that we know that's true. But,
but as far as who wrote it down, in a sense,
we don't know the extent of Timothy's involvement, but we know he's with Paul.
Clearly, maybe Timothy was adding in a few things that needed to be said or,
or not. Maybe it's right. Maybe he was the scribe that Paul was using.
We have no idea.
But Paul referring to Timothy as our brother
would've given Timothy credibility with the Colossians saying, Hey guys,
you can trust Timothy just like you can trust me. He's our brother.
Now, just as a side note, as I go forward, I,
I'm not gonna say Paul and Timothy every time,
it's gotta save some time and some words along the way here,
I'm just gonna say Paul, but I mean both, right?
So you can see why I'm gonna base it there. But that's who wrote it.
But then to whom did they write it? Okay, we need to know who wrote it,
who received it. Well, I've already hinted at that several times.
It's verse two says, it's to the Colossian Christians. Right?
To the Colossian Christians is who they wrote it to. That's what verse two says,
right
to the saints and faithful brothers in Christ at Colossae,
Paul and Timothy to the saints and faithful brothers at Colossi.
Now, a couple things here to help you understand like how to read your Bible.
That's what we're doing here. I know most translations, yours probably does.
Mine does says brothers to the brothers, faithful brothers.
But,
but this letter was not merely written to the men in the church or
even just to a smaller group of men in the church.
'cause later in chapter four it says, this letter is to be read.
When the whole church is gathered together,
which would've included both men and women and children.
It would've had everybody together.
That's why you might never have understood why this is there.
There might be a little super script,
kind of looks like an exponential if you're in math, right?
A little one or an a next to that word, brothers,
you can see it really tiny there.
That's to point you to something down at the very bottom of the page or to
click on it if it's your digital version.
So when you see to the saints and faithful brothers,
you see the one or a it points you down to the bottom.
And here's what this says in my Bible,
something similar to yours or brothers and sisters
in New Testament usage, depending on the context,
the plural Greek word adelphoi translated brothers here
may refer either to brothers or to brothers and sisters.
And so that's what this is saying,
that sometimes this word in Greek is translated brothers,
sometimes just men. Other times,
most oftentimes it's both men and women together,
kind of a group of people, mankind altogether.
And we know that's true that this was for the whole church because later in
chapter four, Paul even addresses women by name within the church.
So again, this is for the church.
This is not a personal correspondence. This is for the body together.
A second thing here has to do with the separation in verse two of saints from
faithful ones, brothers and sisters, saints and faithful. So,
so is Paul here. This, this has happened.
Is he creating a class structure within the church?
Like you've got these extra super holy people over here called saints,
and then you've got people just making it over here, right? The faithful,
faithful ones. No, he's not doing that.
He's merely using theological language to describe the people within
the church
to the saints and faithful ones.
He's saying to the hearers, the church gathered, he's saying, guys,
you are made holy ones by Christ,
you are saints, by Christ. You're forgiven, you're washed clean.
He actually said it to the first, in the first Corinthians,
he said it to that church, to the church of God.
That's in Corinth to those sanctified, that means washed clean in Christ.
Jesus called to be saints together with all those
who in every place call upon the name of our Lord Jesus Christ,
both their Lord and ours.
So there's no room in the church for a special class
of Christian called saints.
You are a saint. If you're a Christian,
you are positionally in Christ. You are positionally,
holy, sanctified, washed, clean.
You have no fear to stand before God if you are in Christ.
And so again, what's he doing here?
He's emphasizing Christ above all.
Because those people know as they're hearing this, they're like, no,
I just yesterday blew it, right? I knew I messed up.
I'm not a saint. But he says to them, no, you actually are.
And in fact, not only are you a saint,
you're also a faithful one because that sainthood,
that holiness creates something.
It creates a response that you are now living a faithful life.
'cause he's heard as we'll see next week,
he's heard about the way they're living.
He's heard about how the colossian Christians are standing fast for the gospel.
And he's like, GA, listen, you are faithful.
You're a saint in Christ and you are a faithful one.
It's kinda like this.
You know those times when you're really down on yourself and,
and you've been just kind of beat up by the enemy and,
and you feel just kind of so far from grace,
you're so far from God and you've, you feel that reality and all you can think,
and all you're hearing in your mind is these negativity,
these negative thoughts.
And then you get that email or that text from a faithful
brother or sister who just reminds you of who they
know you to be in Christ of what they've seen in you.
How encouraging is that? Right? Like you, you've, you've felt that you've,
you hope you've received that at some point where, where you're just down and,
and you pull up your phone. And that,
that brother from six years ago has sent you a text saying, man,
I just want you to know how much an impact you made in my life when you
discipled me for those six months. We spent time together.
And I just look at you as a faithful follower of Jesus.
And I look up to you so much.
Thank you for being follower of Christ like you are.
And all you've thought is, I'm worthless. I'm nothing.
This is what Paul's doing here to start the letter.
If you're feeling down, Colossians, if you're feeling beat up, Colossians,
if you're feeling far from God, Colossians, remember who you are.
That's so important for us, isn't it? Remember who you are in Christ,
you are holy, you are his, and he makes you faithful.
So don't forget that
as we trace this map of Colossians, though,
the next study of it begins to get a little deeper as we think about this
next question. What did they write? Saw who wrote it?
And we saw then what they wrote or uh, who they wrote it to.
What did they write? Well,
look again in verse two,
it says To the saints and faithful brothers in Christ at Colossae grace to you
and peace from God, our Father,
this was following the customary pattern of letters 2000 years ago.
The author gave their name and then they gave a greeting or they gave a
blessing. But Paul didn't follow it perfectly here.
He adjusted it slightly from the usual Greek word re which
means greetings. Like, Hey, what's up guys?
That's how they would typically start to the distinctly Christian word
here, chorus, which is grace.
Not just hi grace to you.
It's the same structure.
He started nearly every of one of his letters with grace to you and peace from
God. Our Father, sometimes he adds Lord Jesus Christ too. But he,
he's wanting people to hear something different than every other letter they
received. But I don't think he's just greeting him here.
I don't think he's just using this as a way to introduce the letter.
I think he is even now giving a summary of his life
and ministry, a summary of the gospel.
Because first, what's the word? He uses? Grace.
He says Grace to you.
Now that word grace means God's unmerited favor.
That it's a free gift of favor and love for you.
That means we don't deserve it. That means we can never earn it.
And so when you think about it that way,
that means grace is like a one word summary of the gospel, right?
This is just it. It's God's grace to us. It's what Ephesians two says,
by grace, you have been saved through faith.
And this is not your own doing. It's the gift of God,
not a result of works so that no one can boast.
It's a gift. It's grace, it's salvation.
Listen, it's still blows my mind
that because of my rebellion against God,
turning my back on him and saying, I'm gonna do it my way because of that,
what I deserve is God's wrath.
And nothing I could ever do could fix that problem.
Yet
the holy God of the universe would love sinful me
enough to take that wrath that I deserved
and instead pour it out onto his son on the cross.
Like that should just blow our minds, right?
What, what other truth like that is,
that is so glorious
Christ above all then, right? Like if that's what he's done,
if grace is what he's given me, then Christ, nothing else is needed.
Just that Christ above all. But
there's actually more grace, but also peace. He says,
grace to you and peace from God our Father.
So peace. What's that definition here would be defined as reconciliation,
unmerited, favor and grace. Reconciliation in peace.
And this word is often tied back to the Old Testament word, shalom.
When like everything is right. That's peace in that sense.
And that is true to an extent, but even fuller than that, this word peace,
the way it's used here is to illustrate the relationship with God
that you now have through Christ.
That's even better than just everything working out right?
Everything is peaceful in our lives. This is way better.
It's, it's the truth that was sung by the angels on the night Jesus was born.
Remember we sing this at Christmas all the time.
Glory to God in the highest and on earth,
peace among those with whom he's pleased.
It's what Jesus preached in Ephesians two. Paul says it to those far off,
those near, it's a peace that Romans five,
one describes that since we've been justified by faith,
we have peace with God through our Lord Jesus Christ. It's peace.
And first Colossians says it's vertical with God, yes, but it's also
plays out reconciliation with one another.
Peace with God and peace with others. As we walk in that faith.
See what we're gonna learn this letter is that there's deep theological truths
for this peace with God in Christ who he is, what he's done,
that we've been made right with God. Nothing by ourselves, all by him.
But then it shows us the practical outworking of that peace in our lives,
in our church, our families, your workplace, your classroom
peace with God shows up every day.
You might even think of it this way,
the grace he's talking about expresses the cause,
right? The the salvation work of God. It's the cause.
Peace is the result.
It's the effect of of the grace,
grace and peace.
And we'll see it all over Colossians.
So we've kind of got this, this map overview so far, but this is a,
this is a little deeper piece next as we get into something a little even more
critical, the question now is why did they write it?
And we saw who wrote it? Who, who received it?
Why did they write it to the Colossians? Well,
first you need to know a little bit about the city of Colossae.
There's gonna be a map up there. It'd be in Western Turkey today.
It was near La Laodicea. You'll see that in the book.
And on the trade route east of Ephesus.
It was on this very long trade route that went from the port cities
to inner of the areas. And, and so they're,
they're in that middle,
which meant that there was a lot of Greek and a lot of Roman people that lived
in Colossae because of that wealth.
And then there was a lot of Jews who had been displaced and landed in Colossae
as well. And so Colossae was a spiritual melting pot.
A lot of different influences all coming together.
And that religious fondue was why Paul wrote this letter to the Colossians,
right? He wrote this because there was a lot of cults,
a lot of false religions already there. And now the gospel had come as well.
So what was happening in Colossae was what a, what we call syncretism.
Like sinking together where you're mixing and matching a lot of different
religious practices and beliefs all together into something that you call new
from different systems. And even the Jews in Colossae were doing this.
They weren't purely Jew,
they were thrown in all kinds of stuff from other people and making a new
religion in some sense.
And so we think that this church in Colossae was fairly young at the time
that Paul was writing this. They were new believers,
immature believers who could be easily swayed by all of those religious
beliefs around them that they could suck into those things just as much as
anybody else.
And so Paul wrote Colossians to address the assaults they were receiving.
But again, he's not responding to just something standard.
He can't just send them a book on Jewish thought.
He can't just send them a book on this specific thing.
People were blending all this stuff together.
Even gnosticism was there where people would say, no,
the body doesn't matter as long as you're connected spiritually with God.
And what that would lead to is people could do whatever they wanted with their
bodies because they believe spiritually.
That's the context Paul goes into to defend the
true gospel. Guys, this is, this is the true gospel.
That's where we get our title here. Christ Above All.
'cause he's wanting to remind them this is who Christ is.
This is what Christ has done.
Don't forget it that there's no competitors to his throne.
There's no other religion that works. He's the head of all things.
He is the fullness of God in him, his life.
Throughout the book you'll see things like in Christ with Christ.
For him through him,
it's is Paul always going back to Jesus as everything.
But, but notice this.
Paul was not merely a systematic theologian here.
He was also a practical theologian where he's writing to emphasize the
things that, that those truths should mean for daily life, for worship.
'cause he's he,
he's talking about the gospel as the only thing needed for salvation.
You don't need anything else.
He's talking about religious practices commanded by God.
You don't need to add all this other stuff. There's freedom in Christ.
Stop getting trapped by all these other things.
So the truth of Christ above all actually plays out in life and in worship.
'cause for Paul, the essence of religion is Jesus.
And the source of true Christian morality is Jesus above all in your life
where you've died to the old self and you've raised to the new self,
that's the true source of being a new person.
That's why he wrote it to the Colossians.
But then we need to ask the question,
this final step of the map study going beyond the
academic, then, okay, why do we even read it?
Why did he write it to them? Yeah, that's important. We need to know,
but But why do we read it? Why? Why is it important for us?
What will we get out of this letter?
What is God going to say to us through Colossians?
Because we have a very different context than 2000 years ago in the Middle East,
right? Actually though,
when you think about it,
our context might not be that different than Colossae.
People are still making up their own truth on the fly.
Whatever feels good at the time
is that not a form of what was happening in Colossae.
We still see a lack of biblical knowledge permeating even our churches where
beliefs that have been held for 2000 years are suddenly
questioned because one guy wrote a blog about it.
We still see spiritual arrogance in some people where they are more interested
in,
in disqualifying others from chasing that prize than
pursuing that prize themselves.
We currently have a large group of Americans blending Christianity
with nationalistic tendencies,
not realizing that that actually neuter the gospel.
We still see some people more interested in following some
externally created code of behavior than nurturing a holy
heart.
We still see so-called Christians living no differently than the world
around us who are thinking they're safe because they prayed a prayer when they
were young. See, listen,
we might be really far distance and time away from colossae,
but the human heart is still the same.
Like we still search after me being a part of a group.
Even if that means we have to compromise to be a part of that group,
our heart still drifts towards sin.
Our heart still wants all the things
that that a flesh is seeking after to be assured of its own
salvation by its own effort. That's what our heart is naturally doing.
And on and on and on, we could see we are no different than Colossians.
That's why we need the letter too. That's why we need this letter too.
'cause we're reading and studying Colossians,
not because we just want increases of our intellectual knowledge.
What we read this for is because we want increases in our christological
knowledge that we need to know more about who he is and want more
of who he is, that he is Christ above all.
'cause Paul lands there over and over and over in this book,
that Jesus cannot be one mere element of some
religion that you've made up in your mind.
That he cannot just be one of many influencers in your life.
No, because he's the source of all life.
He is the giver of life. He's the sustainer of life.
He's the giver of new life.
And that means he should be the center and circumference of all of our lives.
Why? Because he's the Lord overall. He already is that.
And so we in our lives must acknowledge that and come to him in that because he
is Lord over everything spiritual. He's Lord over everything material.
He's Lord over everything external. He's the Lord over everything internal.
He cannot just be a part of your life.
And so we need the Holy Spirit to awaken our hearts,
to see this glorious Jesus,
to see who he is, to see what he's done,
so that then we can give every moment of our lives to him that he is
worthy of it all. Listen,
I need to see him as strong enough to handle my sin,
my past, my shame.
But I also need to see him as strong enough to handle my future,
my temptations, my decisions,
my joy is He enough.
So listen, your salvation does not start when you die and go to heaven.
Colossians will show us that you can actually participate with him in
the power and joy of your salvation even today.
That's, that's what I hope you see through this study of Colossians,
through the amazing grace and the reconciling peace that he
gives us that you would see and I would see,
and we would really believe that Christ is above all.